what's up everybody I'm Noelle Miller
here with my guest kotico what's up et
live I'm the host cody KO with my guest
noel miller here and weird thing about
that is Cody's actually the guest I'm
starting the interview here so I'll be
the host Cody you'll be the host guest
yes and I'll be the host thank you for
joining me thank you so much for sitting
in my in my guest chair on ET live how
you done bump to talk to you talk to you
but yeah three my questions thank God
cool let's so started as the host I have
a question for you my guest who is the
real Kody Co because you bleach your
hair like Eminem so they want to know
who is the real Kody Co yeah well the
real Kody Co please stand up um I'm
pretty real I'm a really good host yeah
I don't know why there would be two of
you anyway
you're not worth cloning in my opinion
now a question for you okay my guess
what is something that nobody knows
about Noel Miller hmm something people
don't know about me is um I'm a huge fan
of acai bowls gasai you guy did you wink
at me after saying that well you know
it's just a thing I picked up being an
acai guy winking is just kind of part of
my secret acai yeah that's how I know
can I get the wink back what is your
life motto
oh let's see life motto do drugs
[Laughter]
responsibly work hard because it's never
too late to make it it's never too late
to make it unless you're thirty then
it's too late
don't try it I have a question for you
Tara yeah what was your first time
bombing on stage ooh this one's fun
never I've never actually bombed it's
crazy I'm literally the world's best
manager him six thousand and zero as far
as killing stages you've done six
thousand shows come on six thousand so
yeah in my head I mean my first open mic
yeah I didn't know I was going up at the
mic I was just yeah you know I got there
and the guy who broke me into comedy it
was like alright you're going up and I
just went up there and blabbered about
nothing and it was awesome because over
time I realize is all Comedy Store
regulars day
they were like who is this person to get
him out of here because and then you
just chose to never get better
I suppose never get better yeah yeah
yeah and surprisingly that works on
YouTube speaking of which what is your
favorite insult okay these questions are
so much easier well you came up with
them you're the host so I'm the host I
did yeah better than your questions yeah
you sir
[Laughter]
classic it's a salad go to what is your
favorite curse word my favorite curse
word uh editor are you ready for this
one yeah boy there's so many to choose
from I have to go the classic Frick you
know I like crap dude yeah yeah dang is
yea hot question for you the fans want
to know okay have you come around on
Pony play yay or nay yet the source name
like alright yeah oh yeah now I get it
yeah have I come around on it yeah it's
still weird to come around on there
everybody there harnessing everything
what Nick level are you hitting these
days we got that is such a dangerous
word man zero man I don't smoke you
shouldn't either drugs his neck level is
his nick levels over 9000 what is your
absolute favorite part about touring
with me absolute favorite part it's
probably your ability to be the slowest
eater on the planet yeah it really
amazes me yeah well it's just fun you
know when we go out to eat and we're all
finished and you're just still somehow a
quarter done your meal yeah cuz it gives
you time to digest and we got a way for
you to wolf it down yeah
why didn't we name our tour the mr.
struggle bus tour yeah
that's kind of good actually it is good
it made me think yeah you're gonna
rebrand the entire tour as a result of
this et live that's good pre-recorded
interview which I thought about that
what was your favorite part about
touring with moi if I had to pick
between tripping over your boots in the
middle at night
roughly ended conversations at 1:30 on
the dot abruptly ended conversations
yeah yeah that was like your thing I
leave me in the front lounge you'd be
having a little boys powwow and like
1:30 would hit like yeah man you're like
all right guys you just go get your
toothbrush okay no cuz it's never yes a
it's always like yeah Wow
no that's you guys are waiting to exit
early the first to make the bed that's
you that's you the res will handle 3:30
in the morning you're like up she's got
a kid up early you had a bedtime now
this is this is a hot one this is a
burning one okay
straight from Larry King what's the best
meat you had on tour tiny or otherwise
animals not included of course who yeah
who's the biggest hunk that you met on
tour if we're talking actual me mm-hmm
the brisket that we had in Houston okay
or no Dallas no Austin Austin yeah the
brisket we had in Austin now am i
answering your question insane yeah it
was fire super far yeah that wouldn't
open for me that I had okay and your
favorite hunk my favorite hunk I mean
our tour guys were on my tour guys right
Tom and Matt yeah I think Tom is the
real hunk though guys thank you so much
for joining us here at et live I was
your host kotico and I just wanna say
thank you to my guests Noel Miller for
joining us today
ya know is very chatting with you my
guest this is your host Noel Miller
signing off here at the pre-recorded et
live segment thanks again for coming on
it yeah no problem we hope you'll join
us again absolutely we'd love to see you
example I'm here every day
because I'm the host oh that's awesome I
mean that's your 24/7 guests good to
know yeah awesome permanent oh great
thank you permanently hosting the guests
here that's what we're doing at ety
though thank you is the host I'm Cody I
was Cody and still I'm Cody and thank
you
still no Elsie laugh get this guy out of
my studio thanks guys okay
please try goodbye thank you
[Applause]
[Music]